this is no 4th of July this is the  national pyrotechnic festival until  protec Mexico each year the city serves  to Pamplona Tokyo Technica or national  pyrotechnic festival for nine days in  March to celebrate the Feast of John of  God the patron saint of fireworks makers  [Music]  local families businesses and firework  factories build enormous bowl-shaped  floats out of paper mache called  Cerritos the construction of which can  take months the exterior of these floats  are completely covered with decorations  and fireworks this is all in preparation  for the festival's most popular event  the burning of the Bulls the Bulls are  paraded through the town and brought  into the square in front of crowds  chanting Fuego or fire a courageous soul  is then sent into light of each blue as  the Bulls are pulled through the  fearless crowd the fireworks illuminate  the town and the party rages on into the  night  [Music]